i just don't understand why he keeps
doing this you don't understand i feel
like it's pretty obvious you just
swallow things
i don't spoil things you're thinking
maybe one thing that i've actually
spoiled
the last movie titled what's up
everybody carlos bustamante here lots of
great superhero news this week
and some interesting info on avatar i'm
not talking about james cameron
this is et canada's nerd alert
we start off with lots of news about tom
holland and his amazing friends
spider-man 3 is hitting theaters this
christmas and it is easily one of the
most anticipated marvel movies
they took us for a bit of a ride this
week when it comes to the official title
of the movie so first they gave us
spider-man phone home
then it was spider-man home wrecker and
then spider-man home slice before
finally revealing the official title of
spider-man 3
spider-man no way home now those other
three titles could be seen as the
filmmakers and the stars having
a little bit of fun with us but as
marvel fans know
nothing is done just for fun
people are going to be dissecting those
titles the colors used in those titles
and what they could actually mean
for spider-man 3. as far as i'm
concerned spider-man phone home is a
clear tease
about the skrull's involvement in the
next movie
it's perfect thank you yeah we don't
really need to start a conversation okay
tom also gave everyone the inside scoop
on what he and the spider-man 3 cast
think of everyone's current marvel
obsession
wandavision speaking with the playlist
tom says quote
i'm obsessed with it it's my favorite
marvel thing i've ever seen
when asked if he is that big guest
reveal paul bettany has been teasing for
weeks
tom jokes it could be me adding
i don't want to say it in case i'm right
and people think i spoiled it because
people think i have inside information
so i'm gonna have to keep my mouth shut
there everyone knows i can't keep a
secret
everyone knows that i can't keep a
secret
keep a obviously speculation is still
running rampant as to who that character
slash
actor will be that turns the mcu upside
down
maybe we'll find out in this week's
episode of one division check back with
me for the recap later on and uh maybe
maybe we'll be talking about it now
while we wait patiently for the
mysteries of juan division to reveal
themselves
marvel boss kevin feige has revealed how
he sees these recently announced disney
plus series
fitting in with the rest of the mcu he
says
quote the fun of the mcu is obviously
all the crossover we can do between
series
between films so it will vary based on
the story
sometimes it will go into a season two
sometimes it will go into a feature
and back into a series sometimes and yet
to be announced
we're thinking of and planning second
seasons for some
of the upcoming series so we know that
one division is spinning off into doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
does that mean
that the show is not getting a season
two with regards to that kevin says
we'll have to just
wait and see kevin feige also talked
about the much anticipated falcon and
the winter soldier series dropping march
19th
and its six episode length he says quote
six hours is what we landed on as the
best way to tell our story
six hours whether it's six episodes or
nine shorter episodes like one division
the shows aren't inexpensive so the per
episode cost is
very high now it certainly seems like
that budget is being put to good use
the show so far looks a lot like the
captain america movie specifically
captain america the winter soldier
and for fans if we're being honest with
ourselves
that's the kind of thing we want to see
six hours of action like that
sign me up you can't just kill everyone
that's exactly what we're gonna do
in non-marvel related news the boys are
definitely back in town
season three is in production and just
look how happy aaron moriarty
and jack quaid are about it same guys
same showrunner eric kripke even gave us
our first teaser image of season 3
with a look at this gigantic homelander
statue
all right hands in the air like you just
don't care
ah homelander humble as always now if
the boys brand of twisted superhero
tails is your thing you're probably
already excited
for jupiter's legacy the teaser trailer
for the new netflix series dropped this
week
it doesn't tell us much but what you
should know is that it's based off of a
comic series by mark miller who knows a
thing or two
about superheroes in conflict he is
after all the creator of kick-ass
and the writer of a little thing called
marvel's
civil war maybe maybe you've heard of it
and finally in wholesome animation news
i'm pretty sure we can all support
nickelodeon has announced the creation
of avatar studios with the purpose of
expanding the universe of avatar the
last airbender
and avatar the legend of korra the first
project
an animated theatrical release
i mean it's it's what we wanted
right i'm gonna get emotional this is
the best news this
is this is not the best news this week
if it isn't i don't know what it is well
let me know what do you think is the
best news this week talk about it in the
comments
down below thank you so much for
watching everybody a like would be great
share this with your friends
if they're nerdy too come on back for
more nerdy news every single week
and uh yeah that's it i'll see you next
time peace
you